what you're about to do in the suit Eric
do you think my book is flying off the
shelves because of this right now oh
absolutely yes I think the shelves are
empty what was that noise oh damn Eric
is that you yeah what happened does it
hurt you to get down and your knees not
really and why you make that noise when
he has to put effort into something
Howard right now in his singlet but he's
in a giant scale all right Eric you're
in there they're strapping you in and
now let's begin JD you're gonna load the
books yes very good JD you're gonna do a
stack of ten at a time yeah all right
let's keep track everyone so Howard here
comes the first step earth back you got
to see this one nothing Eric didn't lift
at all that's 10 bucks second stack 20
bucks and Eric hasn't budged
the scale is tipped to the floor third
stack 30 bucks and Eric hasn't budged
off of the floor JD bringing forth JD's
work out four stacks that's 40 you feel
like you're moving at all no all right
fifth stack fit stack I think I'm in big
trouble
I think Fred's looking like a genius
stack number six and Eric has not lifted
off the ground Jesus Christ
here comes 70 I'm out of the game my
guess was 75 so I'm eliminated here here
comes 80 80 let's see if that way
80 books have you moved at all Eric no
flat on the floor oh this is our first
level we can only get 90 books on the
first level all right
so 90 books are on the scale man
why did what happen I saw a movie over
I'm not sure here we go 100 books Howard
tiny bit and moved to a tiny bit stack
number 11 110 volts is coming up right
now stay common 110 copies of Howard
Stern comes again close to me now here
comes stack number 12 Howard he is off
the floor
here comes stack number 13 this would be
a hundred thirty books I'm out of it oh
my god you gotta watch this now we're
gonna go to single books